[Musica]
[Applauso]
Alessandro era un bambino molto vivace
passava le sue giornate a combinare
delle marachelle insieme ai suoi amici
nel suo piccolo paesino in riva al mare
crescendo però Alessandro divenne sempre
più Cupo e riflessivo e passava in tre
giornate sulla sua roccia Preferita ad
osservare il mare la mamma molto
preoccupata da questo suo comportamento
un giorno proprio mentre Alessandro era
lì seduto sulla sua roccia si avvicinò e
chiese ad Alessandro come mai Alessandro
passa intere giornate ad osservare il
mare e l'orizzonte Alessandro si girò
verso la madre e le rispose mamma
osservo l'infinito e perché voglio
conquistare i confini del mondo e
conoscerlo quel bambino era Alessandro
Magno
oggi non sono qui Naturalmente per
raccontarvi le gesta di Alessandro Magno
Ma la storia di Alessandro ci permette
di entrare sempre di più nel vivo di un
argomento che è molto attuale vedete
l'immagine alle mie spalle penserete che
sia stata prodotta da un artista da un
disegnatore da un fumettista Beh vi dico
che questa immagine è stata prodotta da
un'intelligenza artificiale un
intelligenza artificiale Talmente
potente che grazie ad una nostra idea
una nostra frase che in gergo tecnico
viene chiamata prompt che inglese vuol
dire innesco riesce appunto ad innescare
una grandissima intelligenza artificiale
che è in grado di produrre quella che
oggi chiamiamo arte generativa
Ma naturalmente questa cosa che può
sembrare quasi una magia mi piacerebbe
un attimo con voi esplorarla e capire
che cosa c'è dentro questa scatola nera
che noi chiamiamo intelligenza
artificiale
impariamo a conoscerla
Immagino che se voi abbiate avuto a che
fare con bambini Avete bambini nipoti
sicuramente questi blocchetti colorati
faranno parte della vostra quotidianità
e magari anche fanno parte del vostro
arredamento casalingo i bambini amano
molto giocare con con questi blocchetti
colorati e di solito li buttano a terra
creando questo mucchietto multicolore
Dopodiché Che cosa fanno iniziano ad
organizzarli per colore prendono i
gialli con i gialli Rossi con i rossi
neri con i neri e così via Poi a un
certo punto iniziano a costruirci
qualcosa di solito delle Torrette
colorate poi diventano talmente bravi
che a un certo punto riescono a mettere
a fuoco la loro immaginazione e a
renderla reale costruendo delle vere e
proprie strutture che servono per
raccontare delle loro storie Beh quello
che vi ho raccontato e quello che accade
all'interno di un intelligenza
artificiale cioè l'intelligenza
artificiale riesce sempre a essere più
brava nel costruire
queste strutture a raccontare storie e
addirittura rivolti anche a generare
queste immagini c'è una piccola grande
differenza però che questi blocchettini
colorati all'interno di un intelligenza
artificiale si chiamano dati
per spiegarvi Che cos'è un dato vorrei
fare con voi un parallelismo con il
mondo della chimica a me molto affine
come gli atomi sono i mattoni
fondamentali della materia e noi siamo
costituiti da materia i dati sono i
mattoni fondamentali per l'intelligenza
artificiale
Ma che cos'è un dado la parola dato
deriva dal latino vuol dire regalo dono
però a un certo punto
nell'andare degli anni l'accezione è un
po' cambiata ed è diventata più
scientifica cioè la parola dato a un
certo punto è stata affiancata da
un'altra parola generando la frase È un
dato di fatto il dato di fatto quindi
vuol dire che il dato a un certo punto
cominciava sempre di più a mettere in
correlazione Praticamente i fatti Cioè a
descriverli Ecco che oggi abbiamo quella
che è la definizione di dato oggettiva
vuol dire una codificazione di tutto ciò
che può essere osservabile un fenomeno
un avvenimento
però so che già vi ho perso le
definizioni non piacciono a nessuno e
allora è meglio fare un paragone con la
vita di tutti i giorni e io oggi voglio
fare un esperimento con voi e sono
sicuro che avete detto questa frase
Oggi fa caldo perché ci sono 30 gradi
naturalmente anche un pochino di più
volendo di 30 gradi questa semplice
frase nasconde al suo interno un'elevata
complessità di dati Oggi è un dato
temporale definisce il tempo nel quale
Noi stiamo parlando caldo è un dato
qualitativo Ok definisce una sensazione
30 gradi è un dato quantitativo
identifica Quanto fa caldo e quando noi
diciamo questa frase alle volte la
possiamo dire anche per rompere il
ghiaccio no per conoscere nuove persone
e quant'altro i nostri cervelli si
attivano generano delle elaborazioni le
nostre intelligenze naturali iniziano a
connettersi ed elaborare questi dati
generando appunto ricordi sensazioni
emozioni quindi noi elaboriamo dati
E questa cosa dell'elaborare dati viene
effettuato anche all'interno di un
intelligenza artificiale mediando
mediante che cosa mediante gli algoritmi
ogni giorno segnò parlare di algoritmi i
media ci tartassano anche con questa
parola Ma che cos'è un algoritmo un
algoritmo non è altro che un insieme
ripetibile di istruzioni che persone o
macchie possono utilizzare per elaborare
dati io soffermerei la vostra attenzione
su persone o macchie Cioè anche noi
possiamo dar luogo a degli algoritmi
effettuare effettuando quindi delle
istruzioni ripetitive lo facciamo come
sempre un esempio della vita di tutti i
giorni
Chi è che non ha una casella di posta
elettronica Ormai tutti abbiamo una
casella di posta elettronica molto
organizzata abbiamo la casella
principale i social le promozioni e a un
certo punto abbiamo anche le cosiddette
spam no Casella spam dove finisce la
posta indesiderata ma vi visite mai
chiesti come fa la nostra casella di
posta elettronica discriminare un'email
tra spam e non spam lo fa proprio Grazie
all'algoritmo antispam ma se andiamo
indietro di qualche anno quando questi
algoritmi non facevano parte della
nostra quotidianità Chi è che
discriminava tra spam e spam eravamo noi
eravamo noi che ricevevamo un enorme
quantità di mail e impiegavamo il nostro
tempo per selezionare quelle email che
magari non ci interessavano rispetto a
quelli interessanti
Allora che cosa ha fatto e cosa hanno
fatto gli algoritmi hanno semplificato
le nostre azioni ci hanno permesso di
riprenderci il nostro tempo quindi hanno
semplificato la nostra vita
viviamo in un mondo di dati sentiamo
parlare di dati dalla mattina alla sera
data breach da te Economy data driven i
dati hanno permeato diciamo la nostra
vita
e quindi è importante sempre di più
cominciare a definirli comprenderli e
valorizzarli Ma come si fa lo si fa
conoscendoli tramite le 3v dei dati
la prima V è il volume
oggi noi creiamo e produciamo un enorme
quantità di dati
una ricerca di sigaretta stimato che nel
2025 arriveremo a produrre 175
zbit di dati nel 2025 tra qualche anno
pochi anni
e voi Immagino la vostra attenzione
adesso si sia focalizzata su zetta Byte
Che cos'è questo zbit questa unità di
misura astrusa che non è comprensibile
perché Perché è una nuova unità di
misura che abbiamo dovuto introdurre
perché produrremo un enorme quantità di
dati che dovrà essere appunto definita
con una nuova unità di misura Ma quant'è
uno ZT guardate questa immagine quello
che vedete in basso piccolino quasi
impercettibile è un terabyte l'unità di
misura più grande che noi Adesso
possiamo comprendere quella che è no
hard disk esterni e quant'altro che
abbiamo già nelle nostre case Guardate
quanto è grande uno zbite e nel 2025
arrivano a produrre 175 zbit di dati
naturalmente però
tutta questa grande quantità di dati è
importante poter accedere a questa
quantità di dati in un tempo molto breve
perché è utilissimo poter accedere a
questa quantità di dati ed ecco allora
la seconda V dei dati che è la velocità
è importante appunto accedere con una
velocità molto rapida e come si fa lo si
fa mediante la le api voi Mi direte
Marco ma adesso che cosa c'entra il
mondo della natura con il mondo dei dati
vi rassicuro dicendovi assolutamente
nulla ma condividono il nome perché
quella che state vedendo api gergo
tecnico Epi application programming
interface è una tecnologia
innovativa che permette di arrivare a un
enorme quantità di dati in pochissimo
tempo da come funziona per spiegarvelo
Io vorrei portarvi in un ristorante che
cosa fate in un ristorante di solito vi
sedete prendete il menù Scegliete una
pietanza almeno arriverà il cameriere o
la cameriera
comunicherete il vostro piatto il
cameriere porterà la comunicazione
alla cucina i cuochi inizieranno a
produrre i vostri piatti il cameriere
prenderà I vostri piatti dalla cucina e
ve li riporterà direttamente al vostro
tavolo e potete finalmente pranzare o
cenare
quello che vi ho appena descritto è il
funzionamento di un happy e solo che il
nostro cameriere lpi stessa cioè che
cosa facciamo noi chiediamo alla Epi un
dei dati noi vogliamo alcuni dati in un
determinato modo come i piatti che
vogliamo scegliere dal menù le piai li
porterà ai server questi server
impacchetteranno questi dati Quindi come
i cuochi che producono i nostri piatti e
a un certo punto il cameriere le Pai ci
riporterà indietro questi dati nel
giusto formato e quindi Noi potremmo
elaborarli questa tecnologia che può
sembrare assolutamente
innovativa a tutti gli effetti ha
permesso di fare una cosa
importantissima cioè passare dal
possesso all'accesso Cioè non è
necessario più possedere tutti i dati
per poter elaborare e generare
informazioni Ma basta poter accedere a
questi dati per poterli elaborare e
questo è fantastico
a un certo punto però è importante
riconoscere un'altra cosa ai dati e
andiamo a definire la terza V del dato
che è il valore
i dati sono stati definiti il petrolio
del nuovo millennio cioè gli è stato
dato un valore commerciale monetario
tanto da paragonarli al petrolio Ma i
dati non hanno solo un valore economico
per spiegare per spiegarvi l'altro
valore dei dati Vorrei fare questo
parallelismo con voi con il mondo della
chimica
quella che vedete alle mie spalle è la
tavola periodica degli elementi
è stata sviluppata dalle intelligenze di
tantissimi chimici che hanno dedicato la
loro vita ed è in grado di poter
classificare tutti gli elementi chimici
presenti sulla crosta terrestre
ed è importantissima perché riesce anche
a capire il meccanismo con i quali gli
elementi chimici interagiscono tra di
loro Ecco che allora che se io prendo
due atomi di idrogeno e un atomo di
ossigeno riesco a produrre l'acqua
questo una volta veniva chiamata
Alchimia perché non si riusciva a
comprendere il meccanismo di produzione
dei composti oggi lo Comprendiamo e
quindi possiamo vedere che da due
composti chimici riusciamo a produrre un
nuovo composto che addirittura è che
costituisce il 70% del nostro corpo
Questo è fantastico e allora faccio una
riflessione con voi Che cosa accade nei
dati se io sono pressione sanguigna
temperatura corporea battito cardiaco di
un essere umano
e li unisco a radiografie
si vengono a creare dei nuovi ecosistemi
chiamati previsioni di malattie questo
per voi Adesso vi sembra una cosa
alchemica l'alchimia del dato e invece è
realtà e queste tecnologie e i dati
hanno permesso ad esempio nel periodo
del Copit di evitare che persone
potessero arrivare in terapia intensiva
e quindi prevedere le stadi critici di
covid e questo è molto importante che fa
in modo e definisce il valore sociale
dei dati importantissimo
quindi possiamo dire che i dati
assottigliano sempre di più di quello
che è il confine tra uomo e in macchina
per migliorare la vita dell'uomo su
questo pianeta
e qualora che nascono case Smart dove
sensori dati intelligenza artificiale
migliorano il comfort dell'essere umano
all'interno di una casa
nascono auto Smart dove sensori dati
intelligenza artificiale migliorano il
comfort l'essere umano alla guida
possono prevenire e prevedere anche
incidenti fino ad arrivare
all'agricoltura Smart dove sensori dati
algoritmi intelligenza artificiale
riescono a prevedere malattie ad esempio
dei Vigneti o di altre culture questo è
fantastico e ce ne stiamo accorgendo
negli ultimi anni dell'enorme valore
sociale del dato che può essere
utilizzato per salvaguardiare il nostro
pianeta per un semplice motivo Perché
l'essere umano si è reso conto che non
c'è un pianeta B nel quale vivere Ecco
allora che sempre di più i dati ci
possono aiutare nelle nostre scelte e a
migliorare il mondo che ci circonda
[Applauso]
[Musica]